of the release of the hostages who are
still being held uh the West Bank is
also being affected by an increase in uh
violence uh this means there's now fear
of contagion in 2023 there are attacks
by um violent settlers forcing
Palestinians from the house and also
restrictions on uh movements and this is
hit unprecedented levels and with
it 507 uh Palestinians were killed in
2023 the most deadly year for
Palestinians in West Bank since the
first uh uh survey uh conducted in 2005
60% of the deaths have come after the
7th of October uh West Bank needs to
return to a stable situation
consequences of the war are being fought
across the region with the uh border
between Lebanon and Israel but also in
the Red Sea in Iraq and Syria we need to
continue to work to ensure there's not
further escalation the EU seeks to work
actively with our partners in the region
the EU should play a role as a mediator
between Israel and Lebanon we want to
support uh the uh efforts of the Armed
Forces in Lebanon uh there's also
tensions in the Red Sea and the EU you
has called on parties to um remove any
interference or uh any threats and
ensure free navigation uh the H hooes
need to stop their attacks against
civilians and also attacks against um uh
navigation and trade routes we're
pleased to see the adoption of a un
Security Council resolution uh and this
is something that we Echo with a
statement from the eu27 we're also
looking at the op operational measures
to support International navigation in
close Co cooperation with those who uh
are committed to similar values and this
is specifically with
the um with um other points as well we
also need to support the politian
authority to ensure that uh they can
take over the governance of Gaza The
politian Authority is ready to do so but
they need a huge amount of support the
EU will continue to play its role in
this uh
uh manner last December commission
adopted um a support plan of over 118
million euros uh to support the partian
authority president uh commission
members of
parliament even if we do not agree on
the causes and the solutions of the
current crisis we cannot
um we we cannot allow ourselves to not
look look at the entirety of the
situation we need to find a solution
based on International parameters
including a Palestinian state which
could ensure uh longlasting security for
Palestinians as well as for uh Israelis
all EU member states and the vast
majority of this house agree on this
point and this is something that should
be our strategic priority we need to try
and find a way to come out of the
current crisis thank you very much
thank you very much indeed Madam and now
Mr Lich on behalf of the commission Mr
President honorable members of the
European Parliament Minister
laip more than three months after the
beginning of the Israeli military
operation against Hamas triggered by the
horrific terrorist attacks of 7 of
October the humanitarian situation in
Gaza is tragic the number of Civilian
casualties in Gaza including a very high
proportion of children is
unacceptable the protection of civilians
is of utmost importance and Israel must
do more to exercise maximum
restraint respect for international
humanarian law is imperative and
non-negotiable this is a message that we
consistently pass to Israel and Hamas
must release hostages without
preconditions while Israel maintains its
military objectives to destroy Hamas
with 60% of housing stock and
infrastructure destroyed humanitarian
actors already describe Gaza as an
unable
place a new humanitarian puse is needed
now the situation is worsened by the day
with 85% of population now being
displaced
often living in the open and facing the
risk of famine and
disease the EU is doing its part to
contribute to alleviate the humanitarian
crisis with more than 100 million in
humanitarian Aid in
2023 there have been some positive steps
like the opening of Kim Shalom Crossing
but clearly more is needed humanitarian
Aid and access need to be considerably
scaled up humanitarian actors including
the United Nations whose role is Central
to the relief effort need to be given
unfettered access across Gaza including
the
north the war has Regional consequences
at the border between Israel and Lebanon
but also in the Red Sea and in Iraq and
Syria efforts must continue to prevent
further escalation and the EU and its
Partners will continue to be actively
engaged in this end
The Fragile situation in the West Bank
only adds to the risk of spillover in
2023 and since the beginning of this
year we have seen unprecedented levels
of extremist settler attacks Force
displacement of Palestinian communities
and extensive movement
restrictions the Palestinian economy is
also hampered by Israel withholding
Palestinian tax
revenues in any future scenario for the
day after the Palestinian Authority must
be reinvigorated and ultimately returned
to Gaza they are ready for this but a
lot of help is needed the EU will
continue to play its part in December
2023 the commission adopted
8.4 million EUR assistance package to
support the Palestinian Authority a
larger midterm package will be put
forward in 2024 for this will aim to
convey support to the Palestinian
Authority and lay the ground for longer
term economic and political stability in
Gaza and in the West Bank amid the
humanitarian tragedy unfolding in Gaza
un and other un agencies are playing a
crucial role in facing enormous
challenges I wish to pay tribute to
their staff who do Irreplaceable
life-saving work at Great risk to their
own
lives we front loaded the 2023 AE
contribution to unra in February last
year we hope to do the same in
2024 and we have encouraged Arab and Gul
Gulf Partners to increase their
contributions alt together we provided
almost 110 million in funding to unra in
2023 including a top up of 10 million
last no November to help un face the
enormous challenges in
Gaza and a substantial increase in our
humanitarian support quadrupled to over
100 million EUR in total last year as
already mentioned even higher levels of
humanitarian Aid are being mobilized for
this year to conclude the EU is firmly
committed to work on multiple parallel
tracks stepping up humanitarian
assistance preventing spillover of the
conflict and working towards a peaceful
two-state solution I looking forward to
our discussion thank
you thank
you now the floor goes to Antonio lope
hisis
white thank you president um we all want
the conflict in this room also uh the
the conflict in the Middle East to end
but Madame Minister apart from 5 minutes
talking about Israel it will be good and
it would be a European solution if you
would dedicate maybe one second to talk
about Hamas
Hezbollah and
about future perspectives that would be
a European solution but your people
forgot about
it as nobody can turn a blond eye to the
losses of human life in Gaza and the
humanitarian challenge faced by the
Palestinian people
true as we cannot forget either the pain
of the Israeli families waiting in
despair for the return of their loved
ones we all want it to end and there is
a solution for that the release of
Israeli hostages and the
demilitarization of GAA on 19th of
October this Parliament agreed by a
compelling majority that Hamas can no
longer be part of the future of
Palestine as we have always done we keep
supporting in a two-state solution but
sustainable peace cannot exist as long
as Hamas and other terrorist groups
hijack the Palestinian cause and threat
the existence of Israel the only
democracy of the region remember we are
talking about two parts okay not only
one we cannot ignore either the elephant
in the room the Puppet Master Iran it is
now clearer than ever who is behind and
benefiting for this crisis do we want to
be puppets of the regime by failing to
keep our Unity we are just taking us
further away from peace dear colleagues
at some point this Parliament will have
to make clear choice to say no to those
who murder women homosexuals Christians
Jews to say no to those who reject our
Democratic principles and deny Israel's
right to exist or face a future where
Iran and their proxies will succeed in
denying any hope for democracy and peace
in the Middle East and make no mistake
Europe is the next Target from the
beginning our position was clear October
resolution that we made we set the
conditions for peace I hope and thepp
Will collaborate that we will do this
this time again thank you very
much the next speaker is Pedro
Marquez thank you Mr President min
commissioner colleagues as we speak
bombs keep falling in Gaza civilians are
getting killed by the thousands children
are dying in this de Dreadful War 24,000
deaths 70% of them women and children
and the war keeps going to have an idea
of the proportion of this death toll it
is the equivalent to 5 million deaths if
it were the you population yes 5 million
half of my country's population much
more than many of the European member
states how can this happen and still be
considered a proportional response to
the atrocities of Hamas as it is well
known we condemned in the strongest
possible terms the terrorist attacks of
Hamas we did it by then we will always
condemn it and call for the release of
all hostages amas is a terrorist group
that should be eliminated no doubt about
that but elimination of amas cannot be
done at any cost civilians are not
Fighters children are not terrorists
Collective punishment including famine
and thirst is not admissible those
responsible for terrorist acts and
violations of international law and war
crimes all of them must be that held to
account as always we reiterate our
strong support and Trust on the
international criminal court and the
court of justice no exceptions the total
Destruction of Gaza the flattening of
every inch to the ground will not bring
peace or Justice to the region will not
keep Israel safer the Bloodshed must
stop now humanitarian Aid must be
allowed to access the entire Gaza
urgently and an immediate and permanent
ceasefire must be settled which is the
only thing that can pave the way for any
viable solution the occupation of the
Palestinian territories including Gaza
must end and an independent Palestinian
state must be established following the
spirit of the Oslo Accords negotiation
is the only way forward war and violence
can only bring death More Death too many
lives were already lost it's time to
stop our next speaker is Miss
vman thank you very much president
commissioner Madame
Minister this has been going on for more
than a 100 days this horrible conflict
more than a 100 days the families of the
hostages are waiting for a sign of life
and 10,000 children were killed in by
bombs and
starvation and lack of medical
care and we C we need a long-term cease
fire
and we have to remember that there are
limits to war There are rules for war
and two million Palestinians have to be
provide they need care they need
security and safety two months ago our
colleagues made a very clear resolution
and now three months have passed we have
to strengthen our original message of
course we have to negotiate and but for
me it's completely crystal clear that
what we have to do do is ensure that we
have a long-term ceasefire a two-state
solution I know we're trying to achieve
that I know the European Union isn't
actually in charge of finding that
solution but we have to we have to be a
player in the world stage and speak with
one voice so I encourage all of you here
today with these
negotiations try to find a position try
to find a single position so we can
speak with one voice so that we can
speak with one voice and show the world
with the European
priorities and we shouldn't
be criticizing one party or one member
states we should work together and get a
good
text the floor is yours Mr so has the
floor 100 days of war in Gaza 100 days
of death destruction and human failure
after the massacre of hundreds of
innocent Israeli citizens on October the
7 the massacre of thousands of innocent
Palestinian citizens in the 100 days
that have followed violence breeds
violence and international humanitarian
law today lies under the Rabel of Gaza I
do not question the need to respond to
at atrocities uh such as the ones in
October the 7th what I do question
question is that there was no way to
respond other that the than the one that
has claimed the lives of nearly 20,000
people so far the one that has wiped out
1% of the population of Gaza 10,000
children entire families journalists
doctors teachers and workers from
International agencies you won't
convince me that there was no other way
to retaliate against Hamas disc garage
must stop now both sides must cease
hostilities and reach a permanent
ceasefire all hostages have to be
released and the EU should be using now
fully our leverage to help stop this war
let International Justice take its
course let the courts including the icg
icj do their work so that war crimes and
crimes against humanity that may have
been committed don't don't go and punish
and let's insist again and again that
this entire vicious circle of violence
and hatred will never stop until there
is an independent Palestinian state that
guarantees the security of Israel and
the state of Israel that is ready to
live sa by side with a viable
internationally recognized Palestinian
estate our next speaker is Mr Charlie
rimus thank you uh Mr President the war
between Israel and Hamas is between a
liberal democracy defending itself
against an EU listed Terror
organizations supported by authoritarian
states such as Iran China Russia and
North Korea to establish a ceasefire the
answer is simple Hamas must release all
hostages including the remains of those
murdered and ensure their safe and
dignified return to Israel
for peace Palestinians must end their
support for terrorism their support for
Hamas is at an all-time high a vast
majority of Palestinians support an
armed struggle meaning terrorism against
Israel the fight against terrorism and
authoritarianism must be one whether in
Ukraine Taiwan or Israel I stand with
democracy and freedom I stand with
Israel do you
Sylvia
Lima syvia Limer you have the
floor so you want to talk about the
humanitarian situation of the population
in Gaza a population of which according
to a recent poll one in every two would
vote for Hamas and over 70% approve of
the besal attack on Israel
1,200 innocent men women and children
were
massacred it will be better I think if
you were to uh intensively look at the
Dreadful humanitarian situation of more
than 136 Israeli hostages who've been in
the hands of the islamist murders for
more than three months people are being
tortured they're being violated and
we're also apparently supposed to be
talking about the fact that a
Palestinian Authority is donating
billions to a so-called martyr's fund it
pays for pensions Terror pensions for
relatives of suicide bombers or the
so-called Martyrs imprisoned in Israel
in other words for Palestinian
terrorists murders and
criminals like the relatives of the
murderer of a 13-year-old Israeli girl
who was stabbed to death as she was
sleeping by a so-called Mar this Terror
fund will continue to exist as long as
the EU Germany first and foremost
continue to provide this uh the
authorities with taxpayers money and as
long as you are only concerned about the
humanitarian situation of Israel's
enemies who are also the enemies of our
Western democratic values and our
freedom the Flor is yours
100 days 100 days of the bombardment of
Gaza 100 days of uh uh 300 children
dying per uh per day and over 10,000
children have been died 100 days of
Netanyahu realizes the extreme um dream
of the far right 100 Days with my group
on the left at we've been saying that
our Parliament should act for peace but
today ladies and gentlemen our work and
our determination has actually uh seeing
some uh fruit we are here to stand
against the the right of this hand and
finally we are calling for a
fire uh we are calling for uh justice
and we need to support initiative from
uh South Africa to support International
courts to note the genocide nature of
the action of Israel we also need to
suspend our partnership agreement with
Israel and we need to stop our exports
of arms uh to
Israel we need to stop being complicit
100 days uh where we've seen over 24,000
Palestinians have lost their lives we
won't wait another day we won't wait
another day uh for another dead person
to call for justice and peace
Papadakis Mr Papadakis has the
floor
if it's not
genocide the over 100 days of uh
murdering uh in Gaza what is it the
statistics show it all the deaths the so
many children amongst them the people
injured the people missing and the
people which is facing the threat of
famine they have no food no uh fuel no
medicines and that's why we support the
steps taken by South Africa to condemn
the state of Israel for genocide against
the
Palestinians the uh attacks of the
United States and the UK in Yemen which
is making the situation in the Red Sea
even more dangerous it's the fault of
Israel the settlers and their allies and
uh we now have to put an end to the
massacre in Gaza the uh occupation by
Israel of Palestinian territory
and we have to respect the initial um
the inial borders with their Capital
being East
Jerusalem Mr Galler you have the
floor president president dear
colleagues in
October we had adopted a resolution with
a broad consensus and that was good and
I hope this time as well we can find a
broad
consensus
since some things haven't changed since
October Hamas is continuing to shoot at
Israel and Israel is continuing to
respons and because Hamas is still
shooting and the hostages are not free
well we're in this horrible humanitarian
crisis of the people in Gaza yes Israel
has to respect human rights and
international law when it
concerns humanitarian conditions we have
to address this to ensure that we
uh that
civilians are
not affected from the
fight and I think
considering the supply situation in Gaza
that we have to have regular
humanitarian
pauses it's important that the UN
everyone delivering Aid is able to get
there also in Northern Gaza
so I appeal to Israel not just open k
Shalom but also open
up uh the border crossings in the north
to ensure supplies reach Gaza and then
of course Israel can check and make sure
they're no weapons being
transported our thoughts must be focused
on the hostages and of course the people
in the area and the future and hopefully
hope that Hamas stops its
fight see
you Mrs in is
next colleagues where is our credibility
to be able to demand respect for
international law if this Parliament and
our governments cannot stand up for it
at every time and everywhere let me
remind everyone in here about the
following facts Israel has killed over
24,000 Palestinians in Gaza mostly women
children elderly and un staff since 7th
of October as a response to Hamas
despicable terrorist attacks yes Hamas
should be combed Not Innocent civilians
over 57,000 Palestinians have been
injured more than 85% that is 1.9
million of the population in Gaza are
internally displaced if these atrocities
are not sufficient for us to demand a
permanent ceasefire full support for the
ongoing investigation by the
international Court court of justice
sanctions against Israeli settlements in
Palestine utilization of the tools
provided in the EU Israeli Association
agreement that require respect for
international law including human rights
and to ensure sufficient support for the
important work of unra then my
colleagues I question what it will take
for the EU to
consistently stand up for international
law furthermore I wonder about the
credibility of our Union history is
being written to today and my question
is which side do you stand on
international law or
not the next
ISR Mr kristofh G is our next
speaker Mr President commissioner I
would call on my colleagues to vote for
this resolution it is ambitious and a
strong message the European Parliament
believes that uh civilian lives have a
worth whether they are Israeli people uh
Lebanese or Palestinian the position of
this is B is balanced a ceasefire in
Gaza would allow us to achieve the
release of all Israeli uh hostages being
held by Hamas it would also ensure that
humanitarian Aid can be brought in for
the Civil population in Gaza who is in
no way responsible for the conflict
humanitarian uh Aid is coming in um in a
very low level uh I was at the rougher
crossing point I saw the distress from
the international uh teams working in
humanitarian Aid they cannot provide
support for victims I've seen women and
children who have been hurt who have
absolutely nothing to do with the um the
violence
uh all civilian lives are worth the same
we need to ensure we can meet the
expectations and stop this inhumane
activity presidi how thank you now the
vice president Heidi how has the
floor dear president colleagues
humanitarian organizations have warned
of a total collapse of the healthc care
system in
Gaza uh the heavy Israeli bombardment
makes it impossible to meet the basic
medical needs of the population that is
why an immediate and permanent ceasefire
is urgently
needed the international court of
justice should also thoroughly
investigate the concerns that Israel
violates the 1948 genocide
convention the EU should support South
Africa's intervention in the
international court of justice and to
make it very clear that Israel must
comply with any provisional measures
that may be coming
as imposed by the court so a ceasefire
is a first step and I need to emphasize
that the EU is a key player in the
region and it must work to reestablish a
political Dialogue on a permanent
solution to the conflict the two-state
solution may just be yet
revived thank
you thank you Mr B
y thank you president dear colleagues uh
we are while we are talking now 136
hostages are being held by Hamas and
other
organizations they've been held for over
a 100 days Hamas it does not allow the
Red Cross or other organization to have
access to the hostages to provide
medical support at the same time Hamas
is also stopping humanitarian Aid coming
into Gaza uh they uh block um
convoys they also um leave the civilian
population to uh friend for themselves
this is
unacceptable the uh um f the the
procedure against Israel in the icj is
incorrect we need to have the
unconditional release of all hostages
uh
in Gaza and we need to have access for
the Red Cross as well secondly
humanitarian Aid uh needs to continue
via Egypt and thirdly we need to uh make
sure we're not calling for a permanent
ceasefire because until Hamas has been
eliminated there will be no peace
there'll be no peace for the people in
Gaza the next speaker is Mr
F we are under
attack this anti-h
humanitarian ideology islamism has
attacking us in the west and also
Europe the point is it's not just an
Israeli problem we've seen Terror
attacks against Denmark against Belgium
against Germany against
Sweden all of these promoted by ham
and their allies so this is an is
isolated geopolitical conflict rather
islamism is a fight against Freedom it's
this is an ideology that hates people
who think differently it hates women it
hates sexual minorities and it's against
everything that defines
Europe in our love for democracy our
love of freedom and the truth is
therefore that we only get peace from
this IDE ideology that the day that the
islamists love their own children more
than they hate us and I unfortunately I
don't think that day is coming
soon P has asked for the
floor thank you
president it's incredible listening to
the representatives of the council IL
and the commission here talking about a
military operation against
Hamas it's incredible to continue
speaking here about the fact that uh
Israel is uh conducting Sovereign
defense against whom more than 24,000
civilians murdered and and thousands
under the ruins defending themselves
against whom this is the biggest gap
between our people and the with and what
we represent our people are speaking out
against genocide that we're apparently
not recognizing and we are not
condemning it's incredible hearing how
the representatives of the German
government uh is against the the the the
steps being taken by South
Africa bearing in mind the difficulties
faced by Germany beforehand to
recognized genocide
Holocaust that does not justify the fact
that the EU was a whole not one single
state of the EU has backed the South
African
request the peoples of Europe well uh
know that people here are accomplices of
genocide defending it we have to point
the finger at them we have to talk about
the Palestinian cause which is a
humanitarian
cause
G Mr Kingo is
next dear President we have a very clear
position we are against we can condemn
the
brutal attacks by Hamas but Israel has
the right for self-defense and for the
elimination of Terror
organizations first of all the hostages
must be released and the Red Cross must
have access to these
hostages the event at the Middle East
are
very tragic and more and more tragic
Hamas must not
use people as human shield we have to
avoid the escalation of the situation
furthermore it is very important that uh
humanitarian Aid
should get across to civilians uh these
um funds cannot get across to terror
terror organizations
we have to avoid a re the eruption of a
regional War we have to be
committed against
anti-Semitism here in Europe and also we
have to strive for avoiding escalation
in the region thank you Lucas Mand Mr
Lucas mandle is next thank you very much
president commissioner dear
colleagues you have to keep in mind what
is really happening a state is being
attacked an entire Society is being
attacked by a terrorist act with more
than
1,300 victims children
men and women and then of course the
that country is going to defend itself
it's going to defend itself with an
army which is probably the most observed
army in the world there's no other army
in the world is watched so closely to
see what they're doing how they're doing
it what military means they're using so
in other words the full attention of the
world Israel is defending itself the O
our partner the only democracy in the
Middle East a world that is almost 20
years ago uh left the Gaza Strip to give
it to the Palestinians and what did they
use it for they used it to to create
Terror so we have to
demilitarize the um we have to
demilitarize Gaza and we need a Tribune
but not against Israel but against those
who create Terror Israel is defending
itself and we have to defend our and
defending our us against this Terror and
we have to ensure that how we we should
be
grateful that they are defend ing us
that they're responding to islamist
Terror and of course you always have to
distinguish this from Islam Carlos Mr
Carlos s is next
president president commissioner uh
representative of the council colleagues
everything has already been said we know
the figures the risks increase daily we
know how everything began the terrorist
attack by hammeron the 7th of uh October
was unconscious but we also know what's
happened since then that shouldn't have
Israel has the right to defend itself
and to ward off future attacks however
in doing so they cannot ignore
international law nor undermine peace
and political stability in the entire
region this only creates the conditions
for those who want to see the conflict
spread and the direct and indirect
suffering multiply far beyond the Gaza
Strip the West Bank or Israel there are
three crucial measures to stop this
descent into the abyss firstly the
international Community needs to create
the Diplomatic conditions for an
immediate end to hostilities and for the
negotiation of a permanent ceasefire
secondly we must spare no efforts in
ensuring that humanitarian Aid gets to
vulnerable populations with special
attention to women and children finally
we need to guarantee for Israelis and
Palestinians the right to live in
Security in their own State we need to
achieve this we need to help
people joseon B Mr badas is the next
speaker thank you president now the
ceasefire being called for by the
parliament who are we calling it from it
from Hamas which is continuing to call
on Arab states to uh join the Coalition
and continue receiving support from Iran
or Israel which is defending itself
against a uh terrorist organization that
violated and murdered civilians now and
the ceasefire which is being called for
will not lead to the release of all the
hostages but if Europe really wants to
have something to say in this crisis we
must have a much broader view of the
conflict it's no coincidence that Hamas
attacks um Israel uh Hezbollah is
sending in Rockets uh from Lebanon look
what's happening Morocco as well if you
want a solidarity based uh Europe let's
turn to Iran it's the key player in this
and has two objectives the uh
disappearance of the Jewish people uh
and uh Avid presentability in the region
now we have to look at the question of
uh Israel we wer we haven't been clear
there but I think uh the question is
well do we go along with the US uh UK or
whatever it's time to act and we really
need to adopt effective measures thank
you Mrs nyman you have the floor
dear colleagues the beginning of this
year mirrors the tragic end of the last
one with people in Gaza suffering and
Israelis fearing for the loved
ones and what are we doing wearing Flags
or scarves accusing each other of being
loyal to the wrong side but colleagues
let's not lose sight of what is at stake
hopes for a lasting peace in the region
are shattered again Palestinians are
dying on an unprecedented scale
survivors facing hunger disease and
cold Israel has the right to
self-defense and to bring its hostages
home at the same time civilians in Gaza
have the right to protection and
humanitarian Aid and The crucial
question is how can both be achieved
this is the debate we need to have with
Israelis with Palestinians with our Arab
Partners but before all it seems Among
Us many in the region count on the
European Union to play a responsible
role let's start to live up to
[Applause]
this
Mrs you have the
floor
yes what we have to reject is that and
that we have to see that how the tension
is growing but who's responsible
Hezbollah
Iran so by stop having a ceasefire now
this would mean
that the the terrorists there on the
ground could prepare more attacks
against
Israel yes what we have to do is insist
that the hostages are
released 36 people are still in the
hands of the terrorist women and
children but humanitarian support of the
Civil population in Gaza is necessary
Israel is working together with the UN
and we have to to ensure then that that
we that civil that we support uh relief
for the civilians but it's important
that that this support doesn't receive
the terrorist
number Mr
Timor
president to affect uh the situation in
Gaza we need political and uh uh milit
weight as well but that's all lacking to
the commission now what the commission
would have to do in the future would
have to be ensure that uh unra is closed
down and all of its financial resources
are seized in uh it's not only the
terrorist uh acts which are being um
celebrated but they're asking for
further attacks on civilians through uh
communication channels that they have
Palestinian uh children are um brought
up hating Israeli children and this is
done with taxpayers money it has to stop
any support for the Palestinian people
uh delivery of Aid should only take
place under the protection of armed
troops but that Aid should not end up in
the hands of the terrorists the hammer
terrorists if we want to support peace
then uh I think we would have to
completely stop forever giving
assistance to the Palestinians Mr pimo
lope Mr pimo Lopez is
name thank you president 100 days 100
days over 100,000 victims between those
who have died been injured or uh have
disappeared thousands of uh um health
workers journalists or un workers we've
seen U infrastructure and housing
completely destroyed and almost 2
million people people have been
displaced the the there is no access to
water electricity food fuel medication
and so H hunger is being imposed this is
the daily Terror that we are seeing with
the brutal aggression of Israel against
the Palestinian people the EU cannot
remain comp complicit with Israel's
genocide in the last most recent
European council meeting there was
nothing said about the suffering of the
um Palestinian people we need to stop
this massacre millions of people around
the world are calling for this the UN is
calling for this we need to have an
immediate ceasefire and a permanent
ceasefire need to have access to
humanitarian Aid in the Gaza Strip it's
absolutely vital to ensure that we
comply with uh un resolutions which call
with um uh capital eism capital for
Palestinian State on the pre 1967
borders Saina P Mrs Sabrina P you are
you have the
floor good afternoon everyone over
10,000 children have lost their lives in
over 100 days of war in Gaza and more
than one 100 more than 10 children a day
are losing either an arm or a leg
they'll be maimed for Life the war and
The Siege in Gaza have been
indiscriminate Slaughter of women the
elderly and children from the outset in
the face of so much suffering the only
respons we can expect from Europe is
enough no more indiscriminate killing of
civilians no more bombing of Gaza no
more illegal occupation of the pal
Palestinian territories we cannot remain
indifferent as we've done for far too
long because otherwise we'll be
accomplices to this massacre to the
Netanyahu government we have to say that
there will be consequences unless a
ceasefire is not immediately established
let me make a proposal let's invite the
Israelis and the Palestinians to the
next European Council on the 1st of
February the area of conflict is
spreading to Yemen Lebanon Syria and
Iraq we need dialogue before it's too
late thank
you next next speaker is Mrs
a 100 days have passed since October 7th
when unspeakable atrocities were
committed by the terrorist organization
Hamas against innocent Israeli civilians
but as our attention moves today to the
risks of regional escalation and broader
conflict in the region we risk
forgetting the plight of the victims
forgetting the need for accountability
and Justice and we must not let this
happen we must continue to press for
answers that the victims and their
families deserve the full extent ladies
and gentlemen of the horrors of October
7th are not yet known at a recent
hearing though of the UN Human Rights
Council independent experts were very
clear about the scale and severity of
the attacks particularly those of a
sexual nature in their statement they
noted and I quote that the growing body
of evidence about reported sexual VI
violence is particularly harrowing with
female bodies found with their clothing
pulled up and up to their waist with uh
torn or stained underwear with blood we
must investigate we must find answers we
must understand the full extent of these
crimes because it appears that sexual
violence was not the act of Rogue
soldiers but a deliberate tactic of war
and I hope that you will join me to help
and make the Survivor stories these
women's stories known to hold those
guilty accountable and to bring Justice
for the victims and their families thank
you Mr Udo Bulman is
next president president dear
colleagues I have one
request please make a
contribution that this debate today
becomes part of the answer to this
situation help us that we end up with a
strong
resolution because it doesn't make any
sense otherwise that we were to take
sides with the one or the other and then
contribute to the fact that there was a
spiral of violence continuing and there
are going to be more people suffering
and dying yes there people dying in Gaza
we have to help them we have to give
them food make sure they have water and
Medicine and for that reason we have to
have a pause but at the same time we
have to release the Israeli
hostages and it's not an either or it's
it's at the same time so let's support
the good proposal made by the commission
and the council but I ask the council
and the commission please to debate with
us why our influence in the area is so
insignificant we need need to
politically strengthen our foreign
policy especially in that region so that
that there's an end to the suffering and
so we end up contributing to a better
future thank
you Mrs Saia alalani is
next in an average school in Sweden
there are around 200 children if Sweden
was Raza one school full of children
will be killed every other day one
school full of children would be bombed
by the Israeli occupation forces to
death every day since the Israeli war
against Gaza over 10,000 children have
died many more are still missing buried
under collapsed buildings thousands have
been seriously injured more than 1,000
children have lost their legs if this
not if this is not a reason to lay down
every damn weapon in this conflict then
this world has gone completely mad in
December I visited the Raa Crossing
between Gaza and Egypt and there I saw
humanitarian help desperately needed in
Gaza but not reaching the people who are
suffering and starving suffering because
of the main reason are Israeli bombs
starving because the main reason is
Israeli blockade without a ceasefire
this catastrophe will just go on and on
and the children more children will be
killed I call upon the EU to demand an
immediate ceasefire so our humanitarian
Aid can actually reach to respect any
decision made by the international court
of justice regarding the ongoing
violence in Gaza to raise our voices and
open our eyes to be the Defenders of
every child's right to life thank
you for Mar Mrs is
next thank you very much president if
this isn't genocide then what is it that
is what Gideon Levy asked in the Israeli
newspaper harats the day before
yesterday and then he gave full support
to South Africa's case against Israel in
the he and he described the ongoing
attacks in Gaza and you have to remember
that the big hero against apartheid
Archbishop Desmond tuto was one of the
leading critics of Israel's mistreatment
of Palestinians the most dangerous for
us right now is that we are losing our
credibility throughout the world uh in
our fight for the international rule of
law the situation doesn't look good some
countries are lighting the way but
others remain in the dark among them
Denmark and I do hope and pray that we
get everything in place again demand
peace now and the occupation of
Palestine and make it a serious effort
to find a two-state solution something
we have promised Palestine but also
something we promised the peace movement
Israel a long time ago Mara
Matias Mrs Matias is
next thank you president
24,000 deaths 60% of which are women and
children over 60,000 people are injured
80,000 people have disappeared uh
humanitarian workers and Degen as
military targets since the 8th of
October Gaza is being um uh destroyed
the Embargo on humanitarian
Aid is having huge uh impact and this is
causing an unprecedented tragedy in Gaza
everything is scar basic Services Health
electricity what is happening in Gaza
has a name it's called genocide it's
being perpetrated by the Israeli
government and there's a number of
people who are complic it and this is
because people are afraid of Human
Rights we condemn the the bombing in um
Gaza we need to condemn the deaths of
all these people and this is deaths
which are being conducted by the Israeli
government against international law
we're calling a permanent and uh
immediate ceasefire we call on member
states to stand with uh South Africa to
try and bring back some of the Lost
dignity in the international context
than
thank you I don't see the next speaker
and I so therefore move to Yanina
OA president thank you ladies and
gentlemen members now I am expecting
from the members of the European
Parliament that this time there will be
no opposition to an immediate ceasefire
a humanitarian pause is not enough it
won't stop further deaths calling for an
immediate
ceasefire is at the same time speaking
out against hamas's terrorist attacks
which cause many deaths and huge
suffering amongst the Israeli people but
that suffering does not justify the
death and suffering being caused by the
Israeli troops we should remember
remember that Palestine is its
citizens uh it's not Hamas that Israel
is f Israel is fighting against Israel
has the right to defend itself and the
means to uh to stand up against Hamas
but what about the civilians today who
are victims of these actions I would
also call for the release of all uh
hostages Philipe lazari who is head of
unra says that
today in the Gaza Strip famine is
approaching which could add to the list
of victims thank
you Miss Sant
please for it's been a long time now
Israel has gone far beyond legitimate
self-defense as a result of hamas's
attack what Israel is doing is creating
uh uh a region of famine a region of
death a region of uh uh children without
parents and orphans they're creating
hate in the region they're creating fear
and
insecurity they're creating a lack of
hope uh my friends at the end of
December I was in uh Jordan with a uh
with the delegation for mashrek and I be
a I I saw the devastating impacts in the
region the instability that people are
looking to the future with that can also
uh bear witness to the cruelty and also
the fact that we are just passive with
everything that's happening there is it
is only one way forward there is only
one way which is clear One Way Forward
that is lucid we have one response we
need to have diplomacy for peace
diplomacy for ceasefire and also uh
sanctions uh for the settlements in in
the West Bank and Palestine uh that to
bring forward uh unprecedented
violence Madame natal
looa what do we mean when we say Gaza a
war begun on the 7th of October by Hamas
who were aware of the consequences and
chose to turn the Palestinian people
into Martyrs PR prior to the 7th of
October there were no Israeli troops in
Gaza no Israeli set there was Hamas and
they've done nothing for their people uh
the support for the Palestinians in Gaza
came from as for this period hars um
just focused on the only project which
is the destruction of Israel this
project this war also belongs to the
Iranian regime the Iranian regime is
also incapable of uh meeting the
expectations of their people there is
one thing they're committed to their
ability to har they do so as never
before who supports Hamas Iran who
equips hisbah in Lebanon and Assad in
Syria the houthis in the Red Sea the
militias attacking the Kurds and the
anti-isis Coalition in Iraq who provides
arms to Russia in Ukraine Iran yes we
need to help the Palestinian people put
an end to their nightmare yes we need
massive amounts of humanitarian Aid and
for the weapon and the weapons must for
silence so it can be D uted is Hamas K
forceas fire no they want to continue
their war and call on Muslim countries
to DED arms the Palestinian people
deserve to live in peace and our state
uh and they also need need to ensure
that helping Palestinian people will
help them move Beyond this the strangle
hold that Hamas has enclosed them
inad president thank you this loo more
than 24,000 Palestinians have already
died in the Gaza Strip 10,000 children
under Israeli bombs and I think you
would agree that um one of the things we
owe to the Palestinians facing those
bombs is Clarity and I find it
unfortunate that um renew San s himself
the Renaissance group
supported the deletion of that uh word
permanent from the ep's um call for a
ceasefire are you asking for the
permanent stop to the murder or uh are
you just going to allow it to happen uh
for Israel to build up its stocks again
before it then continues to murder the
Palestinian people Mrs
L Miss auy I can see that Hamas hasn't
called for a ceasefire they are calling
on Muslim countries to deliver further
arms so my question is as follows are
you calling on Hamas to stop turning the
Palestinian people into Martyrs and un
calling uh seire themselves the sey
these people
need thank you president Mrs liso you
haven't answered my question I would
speak out against any War all war
criminals all those people who commit
war crimes I asked you a very specific
question are you calling for a permanent
ceasefires for the Palestinians under
the Israeli bombs now and a second
question you're talking about arm arms
the EU is an accomplice is sending
millions of Euros of weapons to Israel
so are you going to ask the EU to stop
cooperating in this massacre and uh call
for a permanent ceasefire I hope this
time I will get a clearer answer Madame
I know Miss auy that you're speaking
about a world that doesn't exist there's
Hamas which does not want to cease fire
you have an Israeli government which
doesn't want to cease fire and you is
saying that you trust both him and
calling for is far you know it's free
you can you're here you're safe in the
European Parliament uh I myself went to
Israel I went to the kibot where people
were massacred tortured taken hostage I
I saw the unrwa who know that some of
their support is being uh taken by Hamas
they want to continue Hamas wants to
continue the War I just ask you m o to
look at what is actually going on and do
not allow M Hamas to push its
destruction of project of Israel further
forward
so Madame mon sator
my
colleague
whoa wow 100 days of War all out
atrocious War how is it possible that we
came to this how can you continue to
look at what's happening in Gaza without
moving without reacting I asked this
question already back in December one
month on on more civilians more children
and women have been killed more
journalists have fallen on the front
more ambulances have been targeted more
hospitals closed down more homes
demolished and it's not
only bombings there is a total Siege
inhuman uh which in itself is a war
crime one month on more children have
lost their limbs more women have had
cesarians without anesthetic more women
more hunger more cold more despair so
yes Mrs liso we have to call for a
permanent ceasefire now but first and
foremost it has to be imposed
sanctions looking uh all these elements
of genocide there's no longer time to
think about balancing positions in a
conflict a conflict is not balanced
there's an occupier and unoccupied we
have to be against occupation we have to
be clear and that is also what politics
is
about
President
members Israel
says that all of Palestine is
responsible for what h
did civilians are
suffering women and children are dying
and it's very important to remember that
the ecj is deciding whether or not this
is genocide but I think it's very
important that killing civilians and
children is not right children are
undergoing amputations there's no food
every day the situation is getting worse
this has to come to an end
civilians can't be
murdered that's not an expression of
anti-Semitism we have to judge Israel
like we would with the same criteria
that we would any other country what
Israel is doing right now is something
we cannot accept we have to take action
in order that we can find a
ceasefire and that we have a permanen
fire and permanent peace and a TW State
model see
so Israel can do whatever they want
Israel had the right to self-de fense
but this doesn't mean that they can
destroy every building and everything
that breeds in Gaza we cannot um uh
treat in the same way uh children and uh
civilian in Gaza and terrorists more
than 10,000 children have suffered and
uh it's not uh strange that South Africa
has started a court case against Israel
many other countries want to join them
uh so we have the we saw that we have
created a
multi-polar uh government uh politicians
in Iran and everybody is uh uh angry at
uh uh what is happening in Gaza uh the
prime minister of uh um um Hungary has
uh uh spoken against
Netanyahu in the 47 un plan has been
uh implemented about two uh countries uh
and this it is time to realize
that president commissioner the
humanitarian crisis in the Middle East
is a tragedy my country Cyprus is in the
region it might well be small but
nonetheless it's showing the way taking
initiatives to protect civilians creates
humanitarian corridors requires
synergies though and cooperation from
everybody and of course we need a
ceasefire we need it as soon as possible
no one in their right mind wants this
tragedy to continue but at the same time
we have to be honest this arming the
terrorist organization Hamas is also a
priority so that there is no longer any
danger to the people of Israel and
because we're talking about the risk of
a general flare up in the region we
shouldn't forget that some of our
partners who pretend to be our partners
who having supported Putin Hamas
Hezbollah are now supporting the houis
too of course I'm talking for those who
haven't understood to Turkey and Mr
erdogan thank you I'm V
the next speaker is Mr
nimage ladies and
gentlemen there's no end inside to the
conflict in Gaza the situation is
becoming more dehumanized every day
there's no also no end to the duplicity
of the West on the one hand we're
America is trying to prevent the
conflict from spilling over but Israel
is attacking Targets in Lon and Syria
and the West as shooting at positions in
Yemen but so instead of looking at the
causes of the conflict were only
addressing its consequences a landmark
trial has begun in the heg this was
toist as un unfounded in the US and and
and by some in is in the US in Europe as
well and all all countries have the same
obligation and Duty under international
law to prevent serious crime ladies and
and gentlemen instead of deepening the
Riff between the west and the Arab world
we need a ceasefire and an end to the
hostilities in Gaza and the release of
the hostages we need an immediate start
of a peace negotiation without peace
there is not going to be any future for
Israel or Palestine thank you very
much South Africa's case at the
international court of justice teaches
us Humanity aim it times where we need
the most and more African countries
these days followed teaching us what
humanity is together with the majority
of the world They concluded that we are
witnessing one of the greatest
atrocities of this century and they are
right this war has tormented Generations
children's Futures families and a whole
people this war brings out the worst
forms of sexual and gender-based
violence including the Hamas attack on
the 7th of October these war crimes
cannot go uninvestigated and
unpunished this this War forces women in
Gaza to give birth under the most
inhumane conditions and has caused the
most civilian casualties in such a brief
period the world is looking at us how
many more debates are still needed until
we realize that we must demand a
ceasefire now bring an end to this
nightmare think of the children in Gaza
as nothing justifies the 10,000 killed
children and I ask the commission to
maintain the cred ility of the European
Union as human rights Champion if we
fail to advocate for a ceasefire we
cannot lecture anyone on human rights
human rights apply to everyone also for
the people of Gaza thank
you Madame SAS M SAS BR is
next a 100 days of war death and
desolation in Gaza 100 days Israeli
hostages have been held away from their
loved ones 100 days and more than 23,000
Palestinians 10,000 children killed by
the Israeli forces 100 days and over 100
un workers and 80 journalists have died
an unprecedented humanitarian crisis
according to the biggest International
ngos a huge risk of genocide according
to the UN all of that has to end in the
face of this massacre The Silence of
from Europe over 100 days resounds uh
we're looking on but we're not up to it
the EU and the International Community
as a whole have obligations under
international law the European Union
must call for an immediate and permanent
ceasefire the respect for international
humanitarian law the end to arbitrarium
uh arrest and the the release of the
Israeli hostages the adoption of
sanctions uh towards those who are
responsible for for war crimes import of
uh a ban on the import of goods from the
settlements uh and the EU has to become
once again uh a play it for lasting
peace in the region CL the floor is your
Mrs CLA daily you have the floor
president despite the catastrophic debt
toll it is inflicted Israel is losing on
the ground and in the court of public
opinion there's no way that this ends
that doesn't leave Israel a parah state
with occupation and a partide on
borrowed time and they know it so
they're doing everything they can
desperate acts of aggression to provoke
a wider conflict with Lebanon with Iran
with anybody to draw in the US to save
them from the consequences of their own
actions and as Yemen shows butcher Biden
is reporting for Duty with Europe's
froud genocide by his side they are the
ones who have enabled the continuation
of Israeli Terror without them it would
already be over so take note butcher
Biden the ancestors of the Ireland that
you claim to be from disown you keep our
country out of your mouth and as for
verion and genocidal Germany with your
words and deeds supporting Israel in the
icj not in our name the people of Europe
stand with Palestine and with South
Africa
watch Mrs sofka has the
floor thank you very much um on the 7th
of October I was in Cyprus visiting uh
and seeing the situation which Cyprus
member country
lives 7th o00 October was a day that I
it will always stay in my memory it's
something in inimaginable that could
have happened the atrosi is the
kidnapping of poor young people and that
still their families don't know their
whereabouts it's a reminder of how cruel
we are not many of you mentioned the
hostages not only Hamas that is keeping
the hostages in Gaza but they're keeping
hostage the whole people trying to get a
sympathy to the divide Europe and to
divide World whoever is praying for the
voters based on the campaign and
dividing the people of Europe on these
issue has not lived through the war we
have a saying that whoever doesn't and
is advocating for the war and divide and
the conflict let this war be in his or
her house I think that the sad story
about hostages and their families that
they are still waiting for the loved
ones to return home should be the them
thematic of this debate and to all of
those that are using the harsh words I
would just like to to remind them one
day the history will call upon them and
ask them where were you where the war
was on the verge of our homes and at the
last point I just want to say in bosnan
heroina K which is using this for his
campaign he was not fighting and he was
not a a true man he's sitting in a chair
that was provided there by peace and
Reconciliation so let him shut up and
let start reconcilia people in Europe
and abroad thank you madam do you accept
the blue
card
yes
K uh I'm here dear colleague uh you
mentioned correctly the atrocities of
the 7th of October as well the hostess's
questions I'm very surprised you said
nothing about the thousands of
Palestinians assassinated in Gaza
including thousands of thousands of
children why not are you thinking those
victims are and the killers are
Justified and another question uh you
know about the south africas they they
know something about aper heide why they
think they are they are they are putting
the the case of genocide in the
international
is a kind of communist
conspiracy or what okay I will not
contribute to the ele electoral campaign
in South Africa but uh about the
civilian victims what I can say I always
said Hamas is keeping Gaza and whole
people as their hostage not only
hostages that are taking from uh from
Israel's side but the whole these human
Shields that they're using in a war on
terror they are hostages and they are
victims of this war so whoever we we
should discuss how these people should
be saved and not be used as a human
shield from the Hamas terrorist I've
been in a war and I know what they are
doing thank
you Mr Brando Ben Mr Brando Ben you have
the
floor
gra thank you president over three
months have gone by since October 7th
and the humanitarian situation in Gaz is
getting worse and worse over 23,000
Palestinians have died there are over
60,000 injured we need an immediate
ceasefire and the release of all
hostages as requested by borell the high
representative uh to avoid an escalation
in the Red Sea and Lebanon the Italian
government unfortunately has
only done disasters it's frozen
7,000 for the uh UN Agency for refugees
and stopped certain uh projects in
Palestine the West Bank where ongoing
violence is being conducted by settlers
Georgia milone should reply respond for
that shame the International Community
has to step in to uh rekindle the hopes
of a peace process that has to start
immediate for two people two states that
can finally live without fear with their
rights respected too many people are
dying every day there is no time to
waste we need an immediate ceasefire
thank
you
Mr Mr dunda is
next
un the number of people who were killed
in G Gaza every day is now larger than
all the other conflicts during this
Century according to Oxfam inter
National 250 persons every day that's
more than twice as many people who die
in Syria Ukraine Sudan Iraq Yemen
Afghanistan the threat is not just from
bombs raining down on Gaza rather
there's a lack of food
water Health Care
Heating it's
unreasonable that children should be
afraid of going to CH School
that they don't have any
food that mothers have to give birth
without any
electricity without proper health care
we need a permanent ceasefire it's time
for this house to take a position put
pressure on Israel because we need a
ceasefire now here sh
Kelly Mr Sean
Kelly Mar
the atrocities committed in October the
7th by Hamas against innocent civilians
were entirely
repugnant but what we are seeing now has
entered another Stratosphere in terms of
Ordinary People men women and children
being killed starved or left
homeless there have been many comments
in this debate revolving around
geopolitics and strategic interests such
details and and
explanations are of little value when
the reality is a whole population is
being punished for the actions of
terrorists the military campaign in Gaza
is among the deadliest and most
destructive in recent
history not much has been said about
what kind of bombs and artillery are
being used in Gaza but the
indiscriminate bombing the devastation
to the infrastructure and to the whole
population is immense I support the
Irish government's efforts to in
intensify the pressure for an immediate
humanitarian ceasefire
and I call on everyone here present to
do the
same I'm against Hass I'm against
anti-Semitism but I will always stand up
for the innocent Israel has the right to
exist and defend itself it has the right
to get its hostages home safe but
innocent Palestinians have the right to
life not just to live but a life we
needed Seas far and we need it now with
without to Ceasar no progress can be
made and we will never have peace
Kon
Lopez Mr Lopez you're the next
speaker thank you president commissioner
the world is impotent in face of the
human situation in Gaza there's no
justification uh by for the the
atrocious acts that have been clearly
condemned by this house that were
conducted on the 7th of October by Hamas
now we're seeing the Civil population
being attacked attacks on Hospital
critical
infrastructure uh a lack of uh medicines
and the force displacement of uh
millions of people who are trapped in
hell and that's why right now this
Parliament should call for a permanent
ceasefire in what has already been
called for by the overwhelming um
majority of members of the UN General
Assembly a political solution based on
two State solution that will put an end
to the ongoing vicious cycle uh of
violence and a case before the
international court because there are uh
standards which are not being respected
uh we're talking about the situation uh
and stability in Gaza but also we're
talking about The credibility of Europe
as a global actor Mr in fact chair um
colleagues I I wish that we could see
the suffering and Trauma through the
prism of our
Humanity the images of children in
particular are unbearable and this is
not a matter of being on one side or the
other it's human suffering human trauma
we need an immediate and Lasting
ceasefire and long-term peace and
Security will not be ever achieved
without a two-state solution that is an
illusion I would like to highlight two
specific points one is the fate of
journalists a record number of
journalists has been killed injured
assaulted or arrested in this conflict
and that means that we get less and less
information about the situation on the
ground Israel must do everything it must
do much more to protect journalists and
allegations of targeted violence and
killing of journalists by Israeli forces
must be urgently investigated by
independent body and finally Europe and
the US have criticized calls by senior
government ministers for voluntary
immigration from Gaza but criticism is
not enough government ministers are not
random bystanders and if Netanyahu does
not dismiss them his claim of
self-defense sounds even more Hollow
thank
you Mr cff the floor is
yours
we did what we could remember us those
words of the late Dr Mahmud Abu Naya
were repeated by Irish lawyer Bina
before the international court of
justice last
week in Northern Ireland 3 and a half
thousand people died over the 30 years
of our conflict in Gaza that number have
died in a little over the last two weeks
so many innocent civilians most are
women and
children Netanyahu must go he and his
government must pay the price for
breaching international law the
Relentless bombing is preventing
precious Aid and medical supplies from
getting into Gaza children are being
operated on without
anesthesia it is time for concrete EU
actions including in economic sanctions
and banning the sale of Israeli
settlement Goods diplomatic pressure to
end human rights abuses and redoubling
efforts to release the hostages and
achieve a ceasefire we cannot look
awayo
P Mr P Mr President dire humanitarian
situation in Gaza continues and we must
keep this urgent topic on our agenda
agenda along with our strongest
condemnation of the events on 7th
October we reiterate our calls to Hamas
to realize to release all the remaining
hostages the ongoing conflict has become
Regional accompanied with even more
significant Global implications these
will mostly be to the detriment of the
European Union humanitarian Aid cannot
be part of political games instead it
must be based on clear conditionality
rules that are being respected
further to the facilitation of
humanitarian Aid we need a political
solution and the seize of military
actions that continue causing civilian
victims every country included Israel
has the right to defend itself within
the limits of international law the only
viable hopefully feasible solution is
for to Sovereign and Democratic states
living side by side in peace and
security European Union should mobilize
all its efforts to achieve it thank
you thank Madame
Sal thank you Mrs Salo you have the
floor thousands of gazin have have
disappeared and half of hospitals have
are no longer working the bombing has
destroyed much 100 uh 20 some hostages
are still dis dis uh
disappeared throughout the
entire in just 100 days this is a
catastrophe and there is nothing that we
can do we know that the IDF is in the
throws of its offensive now to put an
end to the destruction in Gaza and to
assist the people in Gaza for the
freedom of all hostages to stop the
burning of this region and to finally
lay the foundations for sustainable
peace via the establishment of uh pre uh
peace with the borders of 77 for the
sake of Peace Nelson
Mandela thank you so much Mr lovinski
you have the
floor we are mourning for countless
Palestinian innocent victims so many
children so many
civilians we are mourning for Israeli
victims of Hamas pams baked babies women
raped to death again and again committed
by a criminal organization now hiding
behind Palestinian children shooting
missiles on Israeli civilian cities we
need to ask ourselves where our
responsibility lies for more
humanitarian Aid more precious on Israel
to make this humanitarian Aid accessible
for more restrain of Israel and more
humanitarian law respect our
responsibility for being too passive in
any attempts to reach a durable and just
two-state solution in during the last
years our responsibility for tolerating
Hamas a leadership in Gaza with a
genocidal ideology and our
responsibility today to help
Palestinians but not by pouring fuel
into fire by by using un terified
figures with populist talk Tick Tock
diplomacy which helps to get more likes
rather than more help for Palestinians
we must engage immediately in the region
for a durable two-state solution instead
of projecting our own demons on victims
of our own European
genocides colle lagodinsky and Barry
Andrews thank you president Barry Andrew
is next um we should never Tire of
condemning Hamas and the way in which
they have conducted this war with no
regard whatsoever for the civilians in
Gaza uh however I want to focus on the
humanitarian situation Israel has blamed
variously the United Nations the
Egyptian authorities Nos and gazin
themselves for the failure to deliver
humanitarian Aid blaming and I quote the
capability of the international
organizations inside Gaza to receive
this a Aid the facts on the ground do
not bear this out Israel oper a dual use
list that it has not published and no
humanitarian organization has had sight
of trucks previously cleared for uh
entry can be turned back arbitrarily if
a single item is rejected for example
absurdly a tent pole in an Irish Aid
Consignment the entire Consignment has
to go back unloaded and
reloaded uh there are those who say
let's talk positively what are the
positive proposals but Israel has
repeatedly rejected calls to to
internationalize the inspection process
it is therefore impossible not to
conclude that Israel is deliberately
frustrating the distribution of
humanitarian Aid we need a ceasefire
immediately thank
you
Andrew thank you Mr Andrews we now have
eight requests for catch
the uh this is an important debate so I
will allow everyone to speak dois s is
the
first one
minute 100 days have passed since the
terrorist organization hamus has
committed the biggest atrocity in the
history of Israel we're still receiving
information about continued terrorist
attacks that this organization is uh
doing in spite of this the we can hear
voices of those who are uh relativizing
uh crimes committed by Hamas we should
use this uh debate to once again
strongly condemn uh the atrocities
committed by Hamas and to uh support
Israel and its right to self evidence we
have to say something very clearly
Israel uh will not be able to sustain
itself and as Hamas is destroyed of
course we must do everything to avoid
civilian victims but we must Clearly say
that Hamas is the responsible party for
these victims they are hiding behind
women and children what is especially
frightening is the rise of extremist
uh islamism here in Europe and uh we can
also see various groups marching through
European cities therefore we should have
a zero uh tolerance towards such
Gatherings of Islamic groups in Europe
thank
you I think you all know that catdi
speeches are one minute in duration
Maria arena is
next thank you very
much
[Music]
so let's sort this out and then you will
continue
so do I do we have
English test test the English Channel
are you hearing the English
interpretation uh you can start again
start again
okay the tragic situation happening
before our eyes in Gaza which has
persisted for a 100 days now is
something that at best can be described
as collective punishment of the
population at worst it's a risk of
genocide we have condemned the
Hamas what Hamas did on the 7th of
October but the disproportionate
military response by Israel against the
people of Gaza is unacceptable and is a
total breach of international law we
must therefore
support uh the international court of
justice to make sure that none of these
crimes none of these crimes go
unpunished we have to ask for a
permanent ceasefire to allow the
hostages to be released humanitarian Aid
to enter uh and for the escalation to
stop we need to use our association
agreement the association agreement is
based on Article 2 According to which
Israel has to respect human rights we
are far from respect for human rights
today we should therefore activate
Article 2 uh to stop this
tragedy thank you Miss Arena and the
next speaker is Billy
Kell uh we must continue to condemn
Hamas hisbah and Iran but Israel who
claims to be a democratic country acting
in self-defense but at this stage
24,000 Palestinians lie dead in
Gaza and we have done nothing to condemn
what is happening there we can't even
agree to a ceasefire in this particular
chamber we can't even get humanitarian
Aid into those that are suffering
there's now potential famine hunger
disease no access to basic medications
and we still cannot condemn Israel's
actions of massive proportions against
the civilian population of
Gaza and let us be very clear what
happened happed on the 7th of October
was
appalling but what has been happening to
the Palestinian people for decades is
appalling and is a crime against
humanity and again the European Union
and the member states have never ever
held Israel to account in its breach of
the Oslo Accord its breach of
establishing a two-state solution and
its breach of ensuring
that sorry colleague uh 1 minute is full
some time
ago thank you very
much St next yes um thank you president
I'm I said I'm surprised that some
people they're only uh crying about the
Israeli victims correctly they are
crying but they are saying nothing about
the massacres of thousands of
Palestinians but this is not my point
right now the point is that European
Union is losing another opportunity to
play a role in the international Affairs
Affairs by not following the the United
States by not supporting or tolerating
this war criminal Netanyahu who is
staying in power as long as the war is
continuing because if the war stop STS
he will be judged for corruption so
let's support the South Africa which
brought the case of genocide to the
international criminal of justice and
and let's ask for immediate ceas
fire thank
you Fabio castaldo is
next
thank you madam colleagues whilst we
discuss in this chamber 23,000 people
have died civilians women older people
children how can we uh possibly amputate
limbs from children with no anesthesia
today in
Gaza there is not even a a cry for help
or hope
our uh humanitarian Aid is a drop in the
ocean and as we can see by uh the work
that is being done done by the Israeli
uh settlers it is not enough to clean
cleanse our conscience we need to call
for an immediate ceasefire Hamas needs
to release the hostages and that is only
when we can start a negotiating table uh
by by having two new leaders uh
legitimate leaderships in the on the two
sides and to stop this Bloodshed to have
a Palestinian state which can live side
by side with Israel in peace any other
solution is unacceptable especially
because of the regional uh ceration of
this entire conflict thank
you thank
you and the next speaker is
elenu dear
colleagues there is uh such a huge
number of uh human losses and we need to
bring them down to a minimum we must um
support the delivery of humanitarian Aid
to the U gazai uh population until they
get rid of
Hamas but Hamas is responsible for the
loss of so many people because they
orchestrated the attacks on the 7th of
October these are the attacks that
actually Lo led to Israel uh taking
action there are more than 100 people
that are still uh remain hostage in Gaza
Israel is trying to eliminate this uh
inhumane ideology that calls its
supporters to uh the darkness and to
death and they are supported by the uh
axes of evil Iran Russia and Turkey
thank
you thank
you Milan bre is
next thank you madam president I stand
with international law as the EU and the
European Parliament should so I'm
supportive of South Africa's
complaint at the IC when it comes to the
convention on the prevention of genocide
in Gaza I also agree with the general
assembly of
un on condemning the illegal practices
in the South Jerusalem and in Gaza as
well as all of the procedures at the
international criminal court that are
now in place because of the Israeli
crimes one form of crime cannot justify
another form of crime all criminals have
to be prosecuted South Africa is now
legally speaking defending the honory of
humanity when I mention the West I'm
talking about the USA and unfortunately
also the EU we absolutely have to be on
the side of Palestinian victims and
Israeli hostages and also we need to
sanction all the criminals
thank excuse me can I give one more catd
please so one more catch the
please really okay so okay can you wait
just one second one minute because Mr
Wallace will take his catch the thanks
very much
president 100 days of international
inaction 100 days of double standards
100 days of Israel's genocide against
the Palestinians over 24,000 innocent
civilians dead over 10,000 of them
children many thousands still under the
rubble and is are wondering it this is a
genocide almost 2 million
displaced and still being bombed
hospitals churches MOS bakeries
Apartments bombed and you're still
wondering that this is a genocide and
not one EU country stood by South Africa
Germany is said to have committed the
first genocide of the 21st of the 20th
century in Namibia n's president has
denounced Berlin's shock on decision to
reject South Africa's indictment what's
happened to Germany I've I've admired
Germany most of my life then now they've
lost the plot they've been the
cheerleaders for fueling the war in
Ukraine at great cost to their own
economy and now they're the cheerleaders
of the settler Colonials d project and
support the genocide has Germany learned
nothing from its own
history thank you and now commissioner
lenardic you have the floor to conclude
the
debate Madam president honorable members
thank you for this a very important
debate I'd like to refer to one point
that was made by several
speakers the call for EU to play an
active role in addressing the current
tragic catastrophic situation in Gaza
and Beyond and I wish to assure you that
EU is committed to play this role to
play an active role first on the
humanitarian front EU is the leading
provider of humanitarian funding for
Gaza and for Palestinians in general and
this shall remain so and we shall not
Tire of calling for respect for
international humanitarian law in
particular protection of civilians
unconditional release of
hostages and unfettered provision of
humanitarian Aid throughout Gaza to all
people who need
it second
EU is committed to play an active role
to prevent the escalation of this
conflict region-wide I would like to
recall that earlier this month High
representative borell traveled to the
region precisely with this
ambition and third the EU is also
committed to play an active role in
pursuit of lasting peace in the region
based on two State Solutions
and we are already working on the
scenarios for the day after but let me
underline one particular point it would
help us and increase our leverage if
there were one voice with which European
Union would speak including the strong
voice of this
house that would increase our leverage
that would facilitate our playing an
active and effective role in this region
and we do hope that it would also bring
closer the So-Cal day
after and it is clear that for the day
after there shall be no place for Hamas
to rule in Gaza or anywhere else and for
the day after there should be a
reinvigorated Palestinian Authority able
to take over
Gaza we'll continue to engage
with our regional and international
Partners on all that and we do remain
committed to a lasting and sustainable
peace based on a two-state solution and
we are ready to reinvigorate all efforts
to revive the Middle East peace process
thank
[Applause]
you thank you commissioner lonard
finally Minister Haj abib has the
floor thank you very much honorable
members dear janesh what a passionate
debate and I must say as always when we
speak about the Israeli Palestinian
conflict and indeed the violence that we
see day after day coming from the region
is unbearable and must stop too many
children women and men have died already
and these
deaths be it on the Israeli or
Palestinian side tarish and damage our
Humanity but we need
rationalism and indeed I agree with you
commissioner in any future scenario for
the day after the Palestinian Authority
must be reinvigorated and ultimately we
return to Gaza we all agree that there
is no place for Hamas rule nor does
anyone want a return of Israeli
occupation the Palestinian Authority
should be strongly supported to regain
control of Gaza in parallel and and as I
said in my introduction we will step up
our work on alleviating the suffering of
civilians in Gaza and
elsewhere we will renew our efforts to
prevent further escalation and finding a
way out of the current crisis we will
prepare the ground for a lasting and
sustainable Regional peace and the only
way for that is a two-state solution
based on International
parameters we take note of South
Africa's application to the
international court of justice
instituting proceedings against the
state of Israel concerning alleged a
violations by Israel of its obligation
under the 1948 genocide convention in
relation to the Palestine Palestinian
people in
Raza the icj is currently holding public
hearings on South Africa's requests for
the indication of provisional
measures the EU cannot be a party to or
intervene in a a contentious case before
the
icj the EU is firmly committed to the
rules-based international order as a
principal judicial organ of the United
Nation the icg is a pillar thereof and
has a vital role to play in the peaceful
settlement of
disputes the situation in the Middle
East was already a priority of the
Belgium presidency before the 7th of
October attack and it is at the very
head of our priorities in Council
Belgium was to welcome in Brussels the
Peace Day initiative proposed by the
Arab League the European Union Saudi
Arabia under the uh patronage of Jordan
and Egypt we hope that this initiative
will take place in Brussels soon and
that the conditions will exist to
relaunch a negotiation process we uh
hope that we can count on your support
to achieve this objective in this
conflict which is an extremely difficult
um conflict which makes it difficult for
the union to speak in one voice the
voice of international law The only
voice possible to achieve peace thank
you
thank you very
much that brings to an end the
debate and the vote will take place
tomorrow now we move on down our
agenda and the next uh item is the
report by Alvina Aleta on uh EU India
relations and the rapporter has four
minutes to kick off the
debate Madame President dear listeners
dear colleagues I honored to present the
parliament's recommendation to the
council commission and the high
representative for foreign affairs on
the EU India partnership the
relationship between EU and India the
most popular country and fifth largest
economy in the world is increasingly
important both India and EU are needed
in the fight against climate crisis and
in advancing Global Security the
partnership it's necessary for example
for development and transformation to
sustainable energy for promotion of
Human Rights and democracy and
rules-based international order in the
indopacific region and elsewhere
the current EU India road map that
guides our partnership with India will
conclude next year now is the right time
to step up our Ambitions for the future
and discuss them in the high level
Summit in New
Delhi these themes were also discussed
widely during our visit to New Delhi and
Mumbai in December with the European
Parliament delegation I thank everyone
for this trip India and EU share many
challenges from the climate and
ecological crisis to secur the
environment and Rapid Global
technological developments now more than
ever we need International cooperation
we need International
diplomacy India can also be our partner
in strengthening our diplomacy with
others it is able to speak with the
voice of the global South and able to
help us break the north south divide and
work more together globally we also need
very strong parliamentary cooperation as
highlighted in our report we should
explore ways to establish a structured
interparliamentary dialogue between this
Parliament and our Indian counterparts
we found this very beneficial for
example during our journey in India
cooperation between EU and India has to
be based on shared values promoting
democracy the rule rule of law human
rights and internal law and always
always aiming to improve the lives of
our
citizens we must address the issues of
Human Rights and democracy that are
prevalent and bring them to the heart of
our partnership it might be difficult
but it is something that EU has to work
for as well as India I would like to
thank all of my colleagues for the
cooperation in developing this
recommendation I trust that together we
have created a report that this
Parliament can stand behind and I'm very
much looking forward to listening to all
of the contributions from my colleagues
to this debate thank you all so
much thank you
reporter and now
I I now give the floor to commissioner
Lenard Madame President honorable
members of the European Parliament on
behalf of high representative borell I'd
like to start by thanking the reporter
Aleta and all those members of the
parliament who have actively contributed
to the report on EU India relations the
European Union wants to continue
deepening its strategic partnership with
India India is now the most populated
country in the world and has significant
economic
potential India's geopolitical
positioning and domestic policy choices
particularly on climate and
environmental issues have implications
for the Indo Pacific region and indeed
for the rest of the world it is in the
context of India's steady rise and
Regional and Global power dynamics that
we should assess the Strategic
partnership between the EU and India
broadly speaking EU relations with India
are expanding and enjoying positive
momentum as the report by reporter
points out our strategic partnership
with India is Guided by a bilateral
political framework the road map to
2025 which guides joint action in many
policy areas to further strengthen our
relationship the implementation of the
road map is continuously monitored and
well Advanced the EU and India have a
common in interest in each other's
security prosperity and sustainable
development and together can contribute
to a safer cleaner and more stable
World last year we witnessed the
magnitude and success of India's G20
presidency and we recognize India's
efforts to put the priorities and
concerns of developing countries high on
the
agenda let me continue by highlighting
some recent achievements of our
deepening partnership the relaunch of
negotiations for an EU free trade
agreement with India was a momentous
development back in
2022 there have now been six rounds of
talks with both sides prioritizing a
comprehensive and ambitious Trade
Agreement as the
outcome the EU and India also
established a ministerial level trade
and Technology Council DTC in May
2023 in order to give high level
political steering to our cooperation in
strategic issues at the Nexus of trade
trusted technology and security we
expect to hold the next meeting soon in
2021 the EU and India adopted a
connectivity partnership and together
with the eu's global gateway strategy
and the European Investment Bank we are
making progress in key sectors such as
energy
urbanization digitalization and
transport in addition the EU is
strengthening its cooperation with India
on security and defense with regular
thematic dialogues joint Naval exercises
and closer cooperation in The
indopacific
Honorable members while our our
relations with India are experiencing an
overall positive trajectory we are
conscious of the reports about The
deteriorating human rights situation and
Shrink in Civil Society space which are
addressed at length in your report I
would like to reassure you that human
rights are indispensable elements in EU
foreign policy towards all our partners
India being no exception in this context
let me highlight that the EU is the only
external partner with whom India has a
dedicated human rights dialogue we
attach great importance to this dialogue
and the ability to have genuine
discussions with India as strategic
Partners even on sensitive issues like
this one in conclusion with the world
facing major geopolitical challenges
India remains a crucial partner
strategic partner for the EU our ability
to strategically navigate the 21st
century and work together on key
priorities will bring great benefits to
both Europe and India and to the rest of
of the world thank
you thank you commissioner Lenard for
that and now we're going to hear from
the political groups speakers starting
with the EP and
B thank you chair dear commissioner dear
colleagues this report on the
relationship between uh uh India and the
EU is the second one during um this term
it is a balanc balanced
text it's referencing all the
shortcomings in terms of um human rights
plurality and
uh the rule of law but we also point out
the progress that has been uh booked
without having achieved um the end
results that we uh want to so we want to
point out um the shortcomings but also
um make uh a reference to the progress
booked a reference is made also to the
improvements in terms of uh its uh uh
foreign policy with the EU and globally
there is also reference made of the
worrying situation in Kashmir and also
uh The Stance taken by India in uh the
war in
Ukraine India is indeed a member of the
G5 group and it is in its own interest
to further enhance and reinforce its
relations uh with other parts of the
worlds I
um gave in a number of um amendments uh
to that direction but also to align uh
help India align itself with our values
and uh our amendments had to do with a
strategic partnership between the EU and
India um Maritime safety uh combating uh
terrorism um security and stability in
the indopacific region the uh freedom of
speech and
media the need to uh protect the rule of
law and to set technical standards in
terms of artificial
intelligence it's the first time after
40 years that the Indian Prime Minister
visited Greece and we had an excellent
cooperation I would like to also
congratulate uh the reporter and the
greens for the great work they did on
this report thank you very
much thank you Mr May marakis and Nikos
Pap andreo for the snd is
next dear president
colleagues that India is an important
trading partner uh there's no doubt and
under the good stewardship of raur Aleta
for a change all the political parties
agreed on this report without many
changes that shows how much importance
we give to I would say a new day why is
it a new day because we have huge
geopolitical shifts going on
today China and Russia are not looked at
the same way we looked at them 10 years
ago India is now seen not only as a
trade and a cultural partner but as a
strategic partner that perhaps could
take the place of our past partners and
present Partners like
China and
others the country we agree is a
stabilizing force in the indopacific
region it is important that it keeps
major sea Roots open and provides
stability and security secur in the
region as a whole we call for redoubling
of the efforts in non purification for
nuclear weapons and in a relatively
energy deficient country we still ask it
to reduce its dependence on Russian oil
but I think we need to propose
alternative energy as the
replacement India is a natural partner
for The Greening of the globe its
technical proficiency and Technical
advances in renewable energy are an
obvious area for Mutual cooperation
solar panels pump storage cheap hydrogen
and significant digital expertise are a
strong foundation for creating a more
competitive Europe and a more
competitive India in keeping with the
emphasis that Europe places now on human
rights something that it didn't do 20 or
30 years ago in his trade agreements it
would be remiss if we did did not take a
strong stance on these issues our rep
report points out significant deviations
from the strict dorms of a full western
style democracy we do not expect a
country with such a great history and
tradition to move suddenly into the Nana
of a democratic World however we do
expect the largest democracy in the
world to move forwards and not to move
backwards with respect to Human Rights
and Rule of all over time we hope it
comes closer and closer to the values
that we hold dear to quote from the
report
itself thank
you
marvelous thank you and now on behalf of
the renew Europe groupin
erog Madame President commissioner
ladies and gentlemen
colleagues we're talking about uh
cooperation between the European Union
and India and I want to thank our
rapporter and the shadow rapporteur for
the excellent cooperation which has been
channeled into an excellent report and
thank you commissioner for expanding on
that
report the parliament has
recommendations for Council commission
and the high representative and I would
be very happy if uh the report were read
at those addresses in the interest of an
improvement in EU India relations
we will need India in
future as a partner in order to expand
our economic
cooperation uh in order to uh drisk from
uh China above
all we have discussed uh uh the problems
that we have in relation to India but we
also see India as a partner in the India
indopacific region thank you yeah
thank you Mr eru and now for the ECR B
Yan
R thank you uh chair commission
commissioner in these times of
geopolitical tension and um uncertainty
it is important to start these new
strategic Partnerships and to strengthen
them the European Union and India can
actually mean a lot to each other from
uh in the area of uh trade investment
but also in the area of digitalization
and Maritime safety and in particular to
uh be a counterweight to the increasing
influence of China and the aggression of
China in the indopacific the
reporter taes uh very uh useful
recommendations in these areas but with
her report we also speak about the um
elephant in the room the uh human rights
issue in India which is getting
difficult especially around religious
minorities I'm thinking here of the anti
conversion law and the fact that Hindu
extremists are not being uh punished and
especially make lives of uh religious
minorities and Christians very difficult
over the last few years the intimidation
and attacks on religious minorities have
increased considerably and even ethnic
conflicts which are at origin ethnic
conflicts keep getting a religious
component such as in Manipur India
chairman needs to do more to uh
pursue uh those who are responsible
against uh uh especially uh responsible
in the area of violence against
religious minorities they need to be
taken to uh the courts we our message is
very clear we support uh
intensifying our cooperation in India
but at the same time we believe that
India needs to take human rights
seriously thank
you thank you Mr ryson and now for the
ID group we're going to hear from Cher
Mariani Modi is an important player in a
multi-polar world on the 14th of July
the head of state came to France and was
recognized as a major um player in
diplomacy in the world and now the
European Parliament a few months back
was attacking the Indian president
therefore we should be pleased that our
relations with India are finally getting
the attention that they deserve it is
important for EU and Indian relations uh
as launched in 2024 be a success that
means that Brussels should have a
realistic approach towards New
Delhi now let us be clear relations with
India must be based on Mutual Rel
interests and it shouldn't be just a
challenge to China or
Russia one in five of the planet's
citizens and from India and we have to
uh take full measure of the biggest
democracy in the world as a emergent
power were showing Delhi that our
interest is uh just for a specific
amount of time and not based on the fact
that it's the important economy in the
G20 now it's important for us to support
India in fighting Islam IST uh terrorism
in Kashmir and interference in the of
the pakistanis in the conflict Europe
must stand with those who are uh trying
to assist there we support this
resolution because it recognize the fact
that it uh shows the importance of our
deepening of relations with
India thank you very much Mr Marian now
on behalf of the left group idoya
V thank you madam well let's face the
truth uh the European Union needs to
take clear note and do its homework
especially if you look at the way we've
dealt with turkey and uh uh Israel now
this is important not just for people
who uh are in a situation of immigration
of the uh
lgtbi communities now this type of
intolerance uh uh is is going to end up
being uh to the detriment of everyone
look at netan you need a strategic
autonomy and relations equal relations
on an equal footing human rights peace
disarmament climate Justice and
multilateralism lateralis at the very
center no strategic partnership can be
built taking uh ignoring the uh
violation of human rights of millions of
people not in India or anywhere else
thank
you thank you very much indeed and now
on behalf of the nonattached members ER
sh Madam president thank you European
external trade is facing serious
challenges today and we need to
recognize what Europe's interest is it
is not creating different blocks in
global economy but in developing
economic inter
interconnections our future economic
partners are in Asia and especially in
India the development of trade relations
will benefit not only Hungary but the
whole of the central European region a
trade policy that is based on
connectivity would open up opportunities
for cooperation for example in areas
such as research development innovation
technology Water Management culture
tourism health and
pharmaceuticals but if we don't
recognize that we are interdependent and
we subject the development of trade to
ideological conditions we will
subordinate Europe's interests and we
will make them dependent on external
circumstances thank
you thank you very much indeed and the
next speaker is Katarina kinich
thank you very much president
commissioner today more than ever in a
an instable Global context with poly
crisis with
geopolitical challenges and a
competition amongst the big Powers well
now more than ever a strong partnership
between the EU and India is is extremely
important what we've seen is that there
are strong political and economic and
social and cultural links between these
two sides however this cooperation has
not got up to cruising altitude yet
therefore we need to come up with a
strong strategic partnership that enters
into force in 2025 when the road map as
assigned in
2020 comes to a conclusion stronger
relations between the EU and India in
various sectors that are PRI priority
for example climate action Health Human
Rights and respect of Human Rights
digitization and transport this would
mean that we would have a positive
contribution to global stability and
Regional stability and a broad shared
vision of the rule-based world the EU
must work to make sure that these
conditions are effectuated and more
solid that strategic partnership with
India should be within the interest of
the citizens of the two biggest
democracy of the world thank
you thank you very much Miss kinichi
next is laurance faran who has the
floor
mad Madam chair honorable colleagues a
month ago I went to India and my
political group was represented in a
large number we believe that cooperation
with India is strategic geostrategic
Visa China so I very much welcome this
balanced report which underscores
strengthened relationships between the
EU and India without uh hiding any of
the achievements that need to be
attained in the area of climate and
human rights there is one subject I'd
like to talk about that is investment in
India for Education we've got 1.4
billion inhabitants and uh 40% are below
the age of 25 PE they people have moved
from uh poverty in uh 10 years and they
are now uh working in the tech industry
in the United States so apart from trade
relations we need to innovate in Europe
we need to have an exchange of
competences and knowhow and I think
India is a very good partner to have
thank you Anna thank you very much Anna
fora is next
thank you president I express my respect
to to our partner India acknowledging
many areas of common
interests uh just to name one freedom of
navigation and
Alignment in terms of taiwan's trade and
Red Sea yet we have to express our
concern about the special and privileged
partnership between India and Russian
Federation recently confirmed by by uh
uh telephone talk between prime minister
sorry Modi and and
Putin uh this big and proud Nation
should reconsider eventually some areas
of its foreign policy thank
you thank you Miss fota tanaa is
next thank you chair colleagues
commissioner as a member of Z delegation
which recently had a very successful
mission to Del and Mumbai I would like
to underline the need for mutually
respectful equ dialogue with India to my
regret the report and especially its
chapter on human rights and democracy
violates this principle the report calls
for shared action and leadership in
global Arena on many issues such as
climate environment transport energy
digitalization Health but it I'm citing
expresses its concern for the
deterioration of the human rights
situation and the shrinking Civic space
in India citation end just in India not
in the EU and I POS the following
question to my colleagues do we have the
moral right to teach India on democracy
and the rule of law human rights and
fundamental freedoms while we ourselves
behave badly in the very same area I
also consider as an appropriate an
attempt to give India recommendations on
its foreign policy and relations with
other countries especially China and
Russia thank you m
and
colleagues dear commissioner the EU
India relations have been uh um f built
upon over the years based on
a common
cooperation especially uh based on uh
safety and growth this uh special
relationship has to do with the trade
but also with the future of uh our
democracies the creation of uh the TTC
council is very important in terms of
further reinforcing our partnership and
our cooperation uh in the field of
Technology we also have the cooperation
memorandum of
2023 uh for a corridor that will allow
us to um transport
goods and services from India to the
Middle East to
Europe the Greek government manage to
highlight our country as a a center for
investment and a hub um as an entry
point to
Europe and
the this also pertains to the heracleon
airport in
cre then there is also great interest
for the camata air report it is an
opportunity for member states that
already have excellent uh trade
relations to become this bridge of uh uh
cooperation and trust between the EU and
India thank
you thank you Mr
kopos San is
next
thank
you colleagues it's incredible